okay number 74 in your pre-fundraising
checklist eliminate any other surprise
red flags from diligence this is outside
the cap table now the cap table's got to
be clean understandable and perfect
great we got that done item 74 surprise
red flags here's ones that we see all
the time
an outstanding lawsuit
okay yeah that's material
or a letter or a threat so when you go
into diligence you might see
can you please uh inform us of any legal
letters you've gotten lawyer letters uh
threats of legal action legal action
or any suspected potential legal action
that you think or you know an oral uh
threat of legal action and you're going
to want to make sure that you've
resolved them so let's say you had a
dispute with a former consultant
and they think you owe them five
thousand dollars you think you owe them
a thousand dollars you're going into
fundraising to raise two million
that's going to come up and then a vc
might look at you and say okay
that happens but if there's three of
them
okay maybe the deal's off
and you might look at it and say well
why can't you resolve that so what i
always say to folks is hey resolve that
stuff before you go into your
fundraising they want five thousand you
want a thousand you say them listen i'm
willing to go all the way to the mat but
i'm willing to do it one time
just to get this over for both of us
i'll split the difference with you
three thousand dollars instead of you
want five i want one i'll give you three
if you can do that by the end of the day
let us know either way we're gonna take
it to the mat and we're both going to
lose money on this you can just be
really super candid with that i
understand we disagree about this
can we come to some resolution uh and
you know sometimes you can't sometimes
you can
i have always been of the nature like
when i feel wronged that i do not settle
although i have settled
uh once in these situations um
because it was becoming too legally
costly to fight in california at a
disgruntled freelancer the exact
situation i was talking about and
you know i was just advised like it's
very hard in california they almost
always side with
the uh contractor
your contractor was claiming they were
overtime they clearly weren't they
signed that they were a contractor and
you know it was like okay you can either
pay two or three thousand dollars in
bogus overtime claims or you can spend
ten thousand dollars going to court i
was like let's spend the ten thousand
and then everybody around me was like
jkl please pump the brakes think big
picture and so i reluctantly did that
very hard for me to do when i feel
wronged only one time i did it i kind of
regret it in a way okay
are you paying your rent
out of the business instead of paying
yourself a salary this keeps coming up
people keep asking me like hey can i
rent an apartment to use for a corporate
apartment i'm using my apartment because
it's worked from home don't ever do that
you start to look like adam newman at
wework when you start using
the
company for personal things like an
apartment and then you're like well i
use it for work sometimes i no if it's
your apartment then you pay for it and
then the percentage of time it's not
your apartment then you uh can expense
the company for that and make sure your
accountant believes it and it's pretty
tight uh don't do this kind of stuff the
fact that you have to explain it and
that you're not cheating the company out
of money that means you've lost the
appearance of impropriety is impropriety
don't put yourself in this position
i uh many times will forget which card
i'm using accidentally put something on
a corporate card that's personal and i
am religious about that i always carry
like two or three credit cards with me
so i have like two personal and two
business i literally carry two business
cards and two personal cards because if
one doesn't work
just having to remember that i did it
and if i do have that happen i'm like i
just immediately text somebody from the
company there's a
200 expense for dinner
my personal card didn't work this is a
personal expense i put on the corporate
please make sure you charge me for it or
vice versa hey my corporate card didn't
work i just picked up the hotel bill for
two thousand dollars when i was you know
on this uh trip to new york please make
sure that i get it's on my expense
account right you just want to make sure
you're making that tight another
surprise red flag we see all the time is
people do cash-based accounting as
opposed to doing accrual-based
accounting don't let that drag you down
not being intellectually honest in any
way about the business
you know you put in a consulting project
under your sas revenue
you give somebody the product for a
thousand dollars and then discount it
for 950 all this stuff winds up coming
out when you're working with great
investors and you want to work with
great investors so there's no reason to
bend the truth there is no reason to
break the truth that's called securities
fraud when you're selling when you're
lying and
you are selling securities that's
security for this i think that's kind of
the most basic definition
i think we'd all agree
but bending the truth it's just not
worth it don't bend the truth don't put
you know your pipeline and potential
customers on the same slide with your
existing customers make it three
different slides here are paying
customers here are potential customers
on trial free trials here's our pipeline
of companies we hope to someday land us
clients just be clear red flags you want
to avoid them okay building a data room
this is the sign of a mature company i'm
seeing it more and more at earlier stage
companies because people are doing
fundraisings over zoom
and they're happening faster so a lot of
founders just have their
uh data room ready to go they send
person the term sheet they send them a
docusign and then they give them a
password to a data room this is a place
where all the most important documents
for diligence are kept
could be a google drive could be dropbox
it's very simple but your financials
your p l your balance sheet we've talked
about those maybe the founders their
legal names their emails uh board
minutes bank statements incorporation
documents ip transfers
all of the previous raises and those
convertible notes and saves and of
course your cap table
other items are you know specific to you
know what type of company you are a
consumer a sas company but if you're an
app company you might have your app
reviews in there you might have your app
store sales with like the actual
document from apple like their statement
you might have cohort retention data if
you're a sas company you know sax is
going to be asking for that in his team
over a craft you know just best in the
business that sas
you might have an org chart in there
your number of employees your payroll
stuff that they can verify to make sure
you're a real business
how much money you've raised to date if
there are any side letters uh the name
of your attorneys and accountants their
contact information all basic stuff and
you can think of it as a way to just
prove your worthiness versus other
companies
if they if this stuff comes in and dribs
and drabs what i've seen vcs think is
okay they've been really busy building
their business and it's high growth
and it's growing 50 month over month
okay it's been a little sloppy
we can help them with that they just
need to see a chief operating officer a
vp of ops no problem but if you've been
around for a little while you raised 5
million bucks and it's sloppy and you're
raising your series a or a seed
extension or a series a extension bridge
round
man
that looks lame it looks like you're
sloppy and nobody wants to invest in a
sloppy company that doesn't take this
stuff seriously tight data room equals
easy
fundraising because your credibility
goes up and we're all in a race in this
lifetime to be more credible especially
in the business realm
okay sock two compliance is critically
important why if you don't have stock
too tight you're gonna lose major
customers you just can't close them it's
that simple and guess what vanta
v-a-n-t-a is going to give you 1000 off
your sock 2 compliance advantage
compliance software makes it easy to get
and to renew your sock 2. they
continually test against technical and
non-technical soc2 requirements they
partner with over two dozen audit firms
who have been trained to file sock tool
reports directly within vanta and on
average vanta customers are sock too
compliant in just two to four weeks
compared to three to five months without
phantom take it from kitty hawk ceo john
hegrens he heard me read vanta's ad and
emailed me about how much he loves vanda
i'm kidding you not john told me that
vanto was essential in helping kitty
hawk get stock 2 compliant so they could
target larger customers if you haven't
heard of sock 2 you will when you get to
those big customers so unlock the big
sales and give your employees time to
work on more business critical
assignments like your product like sales
vanta is giving twist listeners a one
thousand dollar discount on their
subscription advanta dot com slash twist
once again vanta dot com slash twist for
one thousand dollars off van ta.com